c'est une petite révolution peut se
connecter à internet sans fil et dans
n'importe quel endroit cette technologie
débarque en france
le wifi c'est son nom sera à terme
accessible dans les trains les aéroports
ou dans les cafés
françois beaudonnet et jean foncé chez
les dix septième étage d'un grand hôtel
parisien
cet homme vient de traverser toute la
france son premier réflexe se connecter
à internet
l'opération dure moins d'une minute
miracles tout se passe sans fil
c'est cette petite carte qui remplace le
câble cet hôtel a adopté la technologie
wifi l'ordinateur du client communique
directement avec une antenne située à
moins de 100 mètres et cette technologie
peut fonctionner n'importe où j'ai
adhéré tout de suite ou wifi passe car
si la liberté en tout point sur mon
balcon et en plus même d'un même mon
bureau mon domicile ma femme a horreur
des câbles donc avec wifi c'est très
simple je connecte et de partout et puis
ça évite d'avoir les câbles qui traînent
partout depuis trois mois l'internet
sans fil déferle en france toutes les
chaînes d'hôtels équipe leur
établissement un service gratuit pour
l'instant on était un service payant
mais qui sera sous forme de cartes à
gratter avec
deux heures de crédit pour 10 euros
environ la folie du wifi nous vient des
états unis là bas des centaines de lieux
publics comme ceux park à new york sont
équipés chaque jour il se transforme en
bureau en plein air pour cadres fatigués
même mcdonald's propose l'internet sans
fil entre deux hamburgers en france le
wifi embarquera début novembre à bord du
tgv paris bordeaux pau dans un premier
temps seules quatre voitures par rames
seront connectés et les services limités
également des films qui le veulent de
des jeux vidéo est aussi leur email
ensuite si l'expérience est concluante
la sncf pourrait proposer le wifi sur
toutes les lignes tgv